609 here on your thursday morning let's
talk about k-12 education in just a
couple of hours educational experts from
across the country are right here in
town sharing ideas to make sure students
get the education we're trying to give
them candace charles live at the orleans
where that get-together is about to get
started candace we're talking about
ideas that have worked in other states
right
that is right nate good morning to you
good morning folks yes ideas from other
states that have worked there hopefully
they'll work here right here is where
the discussion is going to happen and
hopefully those ideas like i said before
will turn into real solutions for
nevada's children now i'm joined by greg
simon from opportunity 180 who's
partnering with the las vegas chamber
for this amazing symposium tell us a
little bit about what you've been seeing
i know you guys work with clark county
quite a bit as well as you see the
numbers throughout the state what are we
seeing right now what are the challenges
that our children are facing yeah i
think statewide and certainly in clark
county we're seeing there's definite
room for improvement you know according
to the last nevada report card about 36
percent of our elementary grade level
students are reading at grade level and
about 22 percent
are at grade level on math so i think
universally we see
statewide and county wide there's lots
of room for improvement and that's
really what today is all about
is seeing how we can make some changes
that will improve student outcomes and
really benefit not only students and
families but the entire community
well that really is you know quite
shocking to hear about those numbers
there tell me really quickly what can we
expect from panelists today so we can
expect a lot of ideas from all over the
country so we have folks coming in on a
national policy landscape as well as
folks from minnesota from arizona
from new mexico who have really put in
place policies and practices that put
students first so everything from
constitutional amendments to literacy
programs to career and college readiness
and workforce pipeline program so really
exciting things that hopefully will be
able to come together and take away some
real tangible actions and and next steps
for this group awesome sounds very
exciting great we appreciate you
chatting with us this morning and having
this event here at the orleans it all
kicks off at eight o'clock this morning
it's open to the public you can expect
to see some people here from clark
county as well again they'll be in the
french quarter room where we are right
now at the orleans for now live from new
orleans i'm candice charles 8 news now